es gibt sie nicht das recht zu sprechen
warum jeder kennt diese situation wir
bestimmt bis heute gibt es viele
verschiedene weisen im leben reich zu
werden man kann zum beispiel eine große
uni gehen bestimmen hinlegen man kann
sich selbstständig machen oder man kann
bravour lottospielen darauf werden
nämlich heute reagieren mit die dümmste
werbung dies auf ganz youtube gibt ich
habe letztens eine gesehen ich will gar
nicht so viel davon erzählen wir gucken
uns bestimmt an aber dann hatte ich hab
mein erstes gedacht warum macht das
nicht öfter mit maximal so wieder so ne
wii action zu machen ich habe wir sind
die zwei im team auch eine ganz gute
kommen hoch vielleicht guckt der
öffentliche druck das wirklich ist
format zu machen leute
aber jetzt will auch nicht lange herum
bravo otto der einfach auf dem ab was
gehört zu dem zweck haben wir den
original bravo otto kanal gefunden mit
66 abonnenten und scheint auch mal eines
der videos an
mit dem titel er berger ist das ja einen
strafzettel wegen falschparkens vergeben
hat junge ich glaube jeder kennt das
problem das ist jetzt die lösung weiß
bescheid abzugeben so ist eben der
gesetzt habe bitte es ist schon schwer
genug ein verpflichtungen nachzukommen
jeder weiß man also menschen die so
dienstgrad zukunft geht
da unterhalten wenn menschen probleme
bitte bitte
es ist schon schwer genug ein
verpflichtungen nachzukommen die miete
zu zahlen und dann noch alle weiteren
ausgaben zu tragen haben so viele
schulden
bitte geben sie uns nicht einen weiteren
es ist noch mal gesagt hat an der stelle
dass sie nun geld hat also ich dachte
ihre katze in der kinderkrippe bietet er
ist einfach so komplett überzogen mit
seinem epting und sie ist einfach wir
haben noch ein kind es wäre das
irgendwie so für leute die gerade
deutsch gelernt haben wir haben ein kind
wenn sie nicht noch geld haben wir
müssen sich in anderen job suchen und
wenn man zu wenig geld für ein kind
hat dann macht man kein kind gibt
sowieso schon zu viele ratten in der
stadt da brauchen wir nicht noch mehr
[Musik]
kurze momentaufnahme da links der teufel
in person hat gerade gesagt dass der
kinder hast und hat sie raten genannt
auch sehr gutes marketing an der stelle
größeren raus und beordert wird sieht
denkt sich so bekommt das ganze land
feiert auch ein bisschen und er mein
hobby hat wieder kampflage ein enorm
geht es gibt sie nicht das recht
zugesprochen
warum rechnen sie denn kürzlich ich habe
gerade eine million euro bei bravo lotto
gewonnen
jeder kennt diese situation hält so ein
zufälliger genau in dem moment vom
ordnungsamt bekommen kommst und mit dem
autos ab diskutiert was per se schon nie
passiert im leben was eine app der manta
b sache ist das diabolo trott das ist
tatsächlich so eine rechtliche sache
aber mit ganz schwierige firma auf jeden
fall ganz schwierig und was ist das für
den spot ich meine das kann doch es gibt
auch niemand ernst und ich habe doch
eine million euro geworden
wir kaufen uns jetzt einen porsche sie
können unsere daten mobil verhalten
jeder kennt die automarke skoda oder
auch das bestellen von skoda abgeklärt
weil es gut aber eben mehr autos
verkaufen da gibt's natürlich noch ein
buch mit dem titel männer sind auch gold
ich wünsche das würde so funktionieren
möchte nimmt man muss sich einfach als
man so die frauen ansprechen so im
alltag packen da da ist es wirklich
wahrscheinlich etwas mehr pro monat eine
million finden glaubt wo man bisher kein
glücksspiel und das ist ganz lieb aber
ist das sicher ich bin muss ich wir
können uns auch nur unterhalten wenn du
möchtest
ich habe eine freundin okay so
fünf sekunden später sieht es doch
gesagt du sollst vom putzen und in dem
moment gewinnzielen lasse
entweder sie ins koma und er sagt er so
was war das für ein geräusch was für die
notification warum machst du wenn du dir
die fresse als ich dachte wenn man wenn
man ab sie ist dann dreht man seine
videos auch so also wir haben da auch
die ganzen schmutz an dieser kamera
hilft wie trainer hast heute ist auch
unsere videos so bauwerk alter absoluter
brother ist eine total genial auf der
schnauze schwarze also das wird schon
wieder so eine forsche gibt's manduca es
gab angeblich eine halbe million
gewonnen ok power up vor dem typen und
natürlich auf
irgendwann gibt es kein propofol und das
beste daran ist es ist völlig kostenlos
und jetzt habe ich gerade hier können
auch also das war der us schauspieler
aller zeiten aber können ja bitte auch
das auf die augenbewegungen unserem raum
hier achten so werden während es gefällt
wird rückt nämlich so zur kamera so
ernst könnte zwar nicht gerade wenn wir
dieses tolle sache so me seite unsere
eigene bravo otto story ich gesagt dass
eine freundin
das heißt freundin also das nicht so so
was ernstes ich gehe da nicht mit gold
dies war von mir
sie gewinnt den jackpot kurs nachdem
sich getrennt hat sie fragen sich was
meinen ansprüchen einfach nicht mehr
gerecht
ich kann es einfach nicht ich habe alles
für dich getan ich habe mein studium
abgebrochen für dich seine familie redet
nicht mehr mit mir
sorry aber mit dem man das ausgehen zu
können muss schon ein lottogewinn
hast du schon vergessen seit dem letzten
saison ich habe alle meine beine für
dich an bord ist
die story wieder da war ich habe mein
studium abgebrochen
die immer verteidigt für meinen vater
jetzt fange ich auch noch an zu heulen
es reicht jetzt wirst doch nicht mehr
drei jahre alt für diesen sachen ich
will mit einer der übelsten scheiß
situation also wieso stellt gespielt ist
gewisse dann doch das ist das geräusch
leute das leben verändern kann
dann geht's richtig ab
ja ich habe mich immer noch was ist mit
i ist ein stimmt auch er heißt
nachgefragt meint also motto zeig mal
her
so gibt man das handy hat sich immer
gefragt was es ist so sitzen sie
nebeneinander so wir können es auch
einfach so stehen sowie 14 so
nebeneinander
es ist mit dem streit
[Musik]
brave leute ist eine total schöne app
die katze wäre tabelle ausdrückt
[Musik]
der mann sieht so krass wie sie probiert
sich an ihren text zu erinnern
[Musik]
so sehe ich aus als in der zweiten
klasse ein gedicht aufgesagt also
bereitet so spät durch nacht und wind
sie sieht einfach nicht glücklich aus
dem traurig noch aussah als würde sie
irgend so eine traurige star weekend hat
erzählen achten aufs gesicht wird die
erzählt es so als würdest du sagen sie
ja ja ja dann ist mein hase rausgerannt
dann kam mein vater wird über auto
braucht keine wette gewonnen
arschloch das leben füllen das ich immer
wollte
hast du das geglaubt dass die glauben
ich wollte dass ich wollte sagen denkt
natürlich meine ich nicht dass wir uns
trennen wenn ich sage dass wir uns
trennen möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen